after seven King Kong movies a new film
will take the giant a in a brand new
direction what if now bear with me what
if there was a King Kong movie but it
was also the 70s called
Skull Island strapped in for a period
piece more retro than a Vietnam vet
blasting Black Sabbath on a reel-to-reel
tape player
in a monster flick that for once
delivers on the giant monster battles
but also tries to be an extended
metaphor for the Vietnam War where Skull
Island is Nam
Sam Jackson is the u.s. Kong is the
Vietcong the giant lizards are the South
Vietnamese and Tom Hiddleston cantata
fighting Dino Birds is you know what I'm
totally lost let's just watch the ape
hit the dragon with a bow propeller
suit up with monarch a company devoted
to launching a giant monster movie
franchise we specialize in the hunt for
massive organisms they'll travel to an
island that's been isolated since
prehistoric times a Jurassic world if
you will - all the chiefest all to have
a place where everything that can go
kong will go call setting up a mad dash
to turn this monster into a sympathetic
character before he fights Godzilla in
the sequel oh he's not so bad
I mean his parents are dead so he's
basically a real a bad man right
remember that time he helped that yak
get ready for a brand new version of pop
culture's best non Donkey Kong complete
with WWE wrestling moves jungle parkour
skills and the inexplicable ability to
sneak up on you like a ninja
he's a 100 foot tall a why does no one
see or hear him coming and shouldn't
have the island be wrecked from Kong
just walking around really guys this is
the best you've got huh
who is that oh no it's Skull Island
director Jordan vogt-roberts hello there
I should have known if we criticize your
movie long enough you'd appear look you
guys can criticize my movie all you want
all I ask is if you do it have some in
merit to it you didn't let me finish
though I had a whole section ready on
King Kong's missing ding dong it was
golden really the where's the dick joke
again as if you didn't already do that
in the honest trailer for Zootopia Donna
pond of the apes and somehow Fantastic
Four yeah well it's no it's not satire
is not bankruptcy you cannot just
declare it relax dude it's just a joke I
love film criticism it's an important
part of this art form but you want to
know who my biggest critic is me you
want to know everything's been wrong
with Kong Skull Island I will tell you
see a skull in Austria by Jordan
vogt-roberts
okay here we go try to enjoy a movie
with major structural problems that
spends the whole first act bringing the
cast together only to split everyone
apart 10 minutes later that was going
for the emotional simplicity of aliens
but ended up with the complexity of
alien vs. predator harsh meat great
human characters like john c reilly
everybody keep your wigs on now then
meat more human characters and more and
more and more and more because most
contemporary blockbusters have too many
characters and most of them should have
been cut or consolidated but hey i'm the
director that's on me like the living
legend John Goodman the guy you enter
the movie with then drops out cuz he has
nothing to do but spout exposition
Toby Kebbell whose greatest Kong but his
human character is in a completely
different movie than anyone else
sometimes laches punching him Bob Tom
Hiddleston the Vietnam vet for hire who
always looks perfect forget the fact
that he's supposed to be a Nam bed in
the 1970s I mean look at that perfect
hair
he never even gets dirty for crying out
loud and brie Larson a photographer
who's essentially playing Pokemon snap
while all the interesting stuff happens
to other people it's a movie that takes
some of our best and most talented
working actors and gives them nothing
that even resembles an arc Jesus is
really honest yeah I bathe in pain so
enjoy a movie that's way better than it
had any right to be but it's not without
its serious flaws I mean it is a monster
movie after all but it is not I repeat
not a problem
that it has too many helicopters wait
what look everybody thinks that there's
some issue where there's more
helicopters in the sky than there are in
the boat and then Kong takes down an
infinite amount of them guess what
you're wrong
there's a shot in the movie where the
camera goes around the boat and you see
in the back of the boat and guess what's
in the back of the [ __ ] boat
helicopters what's inside of the boat
more helicopters what's the boat he made
out of teen helicopters you know why
because you want to see Kong like the
toy has grabbing a keen helicopter you
want to pay $15 not to see and we can
use the helicopter like a baseball bat
the helicopter math makes [ __ ] sense
man this is a really weird on its
trailer deep breaths dude do you feel
better now you know what I do can you
guys just do that funny name thing that
you do you got it thanks man
story Bennet Tom Hiddleston Dirar
say Kong one more time how dare you John
Goodall for your health
gorgonzola Larson let me see that calm
that Kong Kong Kong Kong and a crap ton
of anime references did you catch them
all everything call with Skull Island
and 120 minutes or less to any of you
who think we're just capitalizing on all
the drama we set this up over a month
ago the thing that I'm not looking
forward to is your people drop in some
honest trailer write it I would love to
let's do it
but to be honest we're pretty lucky the
timing worked out to capitalize on all
the drama thanks to director Jordan
vogt-roberts for his honest take on his
own movie click above to see our honest
trailer commentary on how this all came
together I but had banana hammock
fine I'll read your stupid comment leave
me alone you know you love me
xoxo Gossip Girl you know I had a role
in Star Wars
I was the sad